we've been going to disney for a long
time
and we're tired of
the extreme changes that they seem to
think are pleasing everyone when if they
actually spoke to the people in the park
they'd find out they're not
when our annual passes expired in
february we did not renew them
because of our displeasure with the way
disney has gone overall
not just on
that particular issue
but on all their wokeness i feel disney
should take a stand i mean the the
visitors that arrive at
disney world and the other parks
come from all over the world and they
bring what i would imagine is very
supportive view
to a modern approach to lgbt i think
they need to stay out of politics well
it is disney's constitutional right of
being in this wonderful country
if they believe their
thoughts
that that bill should be repealed
that's
their belief and that's their rights
he's right on
we need to protect our kindergartners
and first graders and second graders
they don't need to hear that stuff
desantis to me sounds like a bully and
bullies have to be stood up to i am a
retired teacher
and i agree that that is not the kind of
thing they should be focusing on in k-3
my belief is and i'm a parent myself
is that it is the parents jobs
to teach their children
on the society of the norms
and of this and of the norms of their
household
i don't believe that that is a
state employee or federal employee's job
to teach that to our children or to
anyone else these days worldwide
you know the whole lgbt situation is
just accepted
and embraced
it doesn't lead negativity
around it everything he's doing is
protecting families and protecting the
people in the state and i just love
everything he's doing
there's a lot more
important
topics those kids could be learning and
i think they need to be given a chance
to develop themselves
before
they start being taught
about what
they should be
you